[Music]
no no no no everybody be cool I knew I
had it big with this movie it's time to
get down and dirty
ninja-style the past of this is bananas
I mean it's really like the most
talented funniest people you're gonna be
fine let me text your mother Lloyd is
you know he's a complicated guy who has
a father who's an evil warlord no noise
it's void dad he's been living in his
shadow his whole life at his heart he's
a great friend and he's a great leader I
believe in each of you Lloyd Garmadon is
he's narcissistic van guy who is always
trying to sort of rule over and jog when
I cry which I said can do I weep tears
of fire
guys supposed to be the hothead
he's a fire Zane is the robot who has
applications to being a real live team
birthday hug let me get in on that all
increase the pressure dramatically I
play Jay and he's the blue ninja
electricity he wants to be cool but he
really can't be nobody's parents are
perfect
my mom is weird and collects seashell
your dad level cities and attacks
innocent people so they've all got that
quark Mia is the only girl in the ninja
game she's fiercely independent she is
not some sidekick in the gang she's a
really powerful part of it
what a game my character Cole is more
laid-back than the other ninjas yeah
watch this what Masaru is the founder of
the secret ninja force no in teaches
students how to become perfect ninja
Coco's roid mom and she's very sweet but
she just tries to be a big beacon of
positivity and light for him oh and also
don't forget if your dad attacks the
city again today just be sure to duck
clear it was kind of intimidating
because it literally was like The Improv
Olympics 10 for 10:40 with the 10 for
1041 I have no idea what you're saying
to me right now
it's just a pile of words falling right
out of your mouth now ninja goes there
everyone and recording with all the
other cast members is really really
exciting because you could just kind of
play around and see what would happen
you know how did you gain two arms I was
bit by snake no yes they have arms
exactly do you mean like a spider oh no
I was bit by a snake yeah then the snake
had been bitten by a spider and then the
snake bit me so that's why are you guys
actually buying any of this how else
would you explain it the Lord you
weren't there
voicing a character and
it was much more freewheeling and it
creates a kind of spun that Lloyd's on
his own journey to sort of find himself
but like all good teams and you gotta
operate within a group throughout the
story they realized that it is about
believing in yourself and then just
finding that inner peace and peace has
felt piee which I do think is one of
those where it is fun is a long time
the fate of Ninjago is in your hands are
you ready yes I am on it yeah maybe
[Music]
you ready Femina continent jackal
I'll be waiting
dad sorry what was that last thing you
said what that last part they didn't
catch it well is anything what do you
mean I didn't well I said I'll be
waiting and then I stopped talking dad
no Lloyd that's right your son and it's
Lloyd no ll o yd I named you you've
ruined my life
that's not true I haven't even been a
part of your life how could I ruin it
wasn't even there baby now we got bad
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm kicking ass animals to form the
secret ninja force are you ready to risk
your life but Ninjago yes I am maybe I
know you want me to save myself
[Music]
hello who is this Lloyd Garmadon your
son hmm
[Music]
it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect I mean my mom is weird
and collect seashells your dad levels
cities and attacks innocent people so
they've all got that quarks you know
[Music]